deliver us the moon for the livers  please  this is death he is offering Sam a deal  that he can't refuse  now Sam has to live for 24 hours doing  every bodily function manually brush  your teeth put on pants breathe in  breathe out  brilliant stamp walk struggle cut cry  why is his face turning blue breathe in  breathe out breathe in breathe out a  tale about love friendship a humanity  grew fearful of our discovery  so now we are 400 million miles away  from home with no so how's the family  back a no lighting in keeping up with  the Joneses it's our autonomous beverage  dispensing robot Gerty weightlessness  doesn't affect me my affinity with the  working class keeps me grounded  I'm doing everything that I can Nate  please don't say that we don't know Nate  don't look I think you should come home  just for a couple of days to help me  look for him the police obviously don't  give a [ __ ]